I am in New York I am on my holidays but
there is so much going on with Stargate
right now I just had to do this really
quick and dirty video to discuss a few
of the rumors and a few of the news
that's happening so welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
so again I'm going to apologize this
editing is I I don't have time to edit
this video so I apologize in advance
it's going to be a bit rude but
there's a lot of things going on right
so now apparently
Stargate is going to be leaving Prime
very very shortly in the United States
and
it was supposed to be going on to Prime
in Europe by now but it hasn't now I was
told back in July that
um during marketing meetings and things
they had decided the Stargate would go
on worldwide Prime
by around Christmas so it should be we
should all have it by now
but we don't
now we've obviously been getting a lot
of these rumors about Mark Fergus and um
that actually negotiations have started
about
um them producing a new Stargate TV show
now the now they've Mark Ferguson
penguin and Parker have also got the um
God of War TV show for Netflix now I've
known about that for like six months
I've actually known about that since
March just gone so they were developing
that so I'm not concerned about that
um in respect to them then doing
Stargate as well the rumor I'm hearing
basically is that Mark Fergus will do
Stargate and Hawk ostpy is doing God of
War but also actually a lot of the work
has already been done so again we don't
need to worry about it I'm hearing loads
and loads of rumors about Stargate as
well so many rumors that I I will do a
video just so I will just list them all
off because I don't actually believe a
lot of them
but they are coming from sources even my
sources are saying look I've been told
this and I'm not sure it's true so it
does make me wonder whether actually
Amazon
are flooding their Channels with news
now because and this is really the point
of the video is something about to
happen or has something changed now
Amazon know that we are doing lots and
lots of videos and they know we're
talking about Stargate they know we're
talking about anything and they know
about Sidetrack which is ridiculous but
I know my sources keep telling me
um they keep getting memos and and
things and their managers keep saying
look there's this channel they've got a
lot of rumors they shouldn't have
somebody's talking stop it
um I know that gateworld and everything
that they get mentioned as well now
that's because Amazon don't necessarily
want us to know they don't want us to
know what's going on
so one way they can confuse the
situation if something is about to get
announced or they are working on
something is to then like flood the
channels with loads of false information
which I do think happens I actually know
Amazon do that so that that's that but
then that gives me hope that something's
happening a lot of information is maybe
because something is about to happen now
I was always told it's when the rumors
stop that you should get excited and the
rumors did stop for a good two or three
months we didn't hear really anything
new about Stargate for a long while and
now all of a sudden we're hearing lots
of information
that the problem with that is is the
mark Fergus rumor fake news is that
something that Amazon have put out
to confuse us I don't think so
um like I said the guy that I speak to
is is adamant that it's true and the
contract negotiation started about a
month ago
so we I'm really reasonably confident
that that's true there's a lot of other
rumors that again I will tell you about
in another video because I don't really
have time right now
um I'll tell you soon as I get back that
I think is false including that there is
actually another company that is also
negotiating currently with Amazon to
produce it now that could be that Amazon
is just not putting their eggs in one
basket
could be that the negotiations that that
person is talking about actually isn't
to produce the show it's because more
than one production company will end up
doing Stargate penguin and Parker will
develop and produce but then another
company will actually have to make the
show a company that actually owns a
studio so it could be that company's
talking about or it could be that
penguin in a Parker isn't a done deal
and Amazon is still talking to other
people so we don't really know at this
point so these are all rumors but you
know conjecture
um we'll find out soon hopefully but I'm
hearing a bunch of other rumors as well
including about some actors that might
return one really surprised me but again
I'll talk about another video because
I'm still waiting for some information
on that but this Stargate being removed
from Prime what the hell does that mean
well I can think of a couple of
possibilities because I've been on there
a few months it's not been on there very
long
one possibility is that they are about
to announce Stargate
and that they want
Stargate sg1 SG USGA to be behind a
firewall so they want people to have to
pay for it because they know there's
about to be a lot of interest in it
it could be that Stargate is going to be
removed from Prime because actually
Amazon have decided to push forward with
epics in MGM plus and that it's going to
go on to MGM Plus in the United States
which actually would kind of make sense
and would be kind of what we thought
they were going to do originally
so is it that they've put it on epics so
they've put it on Amazon Prime just to
tease us then they're going to move on
to epics
now I've not heard anything about this
but I do and I've told you guys before
they are really interested in pushing
epics and MGM plus when it's when it
moves over to MGM plus they really do
Amazon really do want to make that a big
stream of service they are really
putting a lot of effort into it I've
already told you that I'm being told
that when new Stargate comes it will go
on MGM Plus in the United States
so in that case it makes sense that they
would put existing Stargate onto MGM
plus and that it would go off Prime
about now which makes sense
and then mid-January will go into MGM
Plus
I'm not hearing I haven't heard anything
from any of the guys I speak to that
that's what the plan is but obviously I
don't speak to everybody that works at
MGM so you know someone's got by me
there
but why hasn't it gone Amazon Prime in
the UK
there now there isn't there is a channel
in the uh in the UK in Europe MGM at the
moment and apparently you've just been
rebranded MGM plus it's five pound a
month
as part of Amazon Prime now I heard that
they weren't going to be pushing that
and that actually Stargate was going to
go on to Amazon Prime
now again conjecture here I'm wondering
if they're holding off
putting Stargate on Amazon Prime in the
rest of Europe because they're going to
announce all this in one hit now again
this is conjecture but it makes sense
are they going to announce MGM Plus
with Stargate sg1 sgusga on
that service in the United States
and put it on Prime in the UK at the
same time they announced the new series
if you think about it that is an awful
lot of very good positive news
so again we're still in this holding
pattern that we're waiting for
mid-January
so is it a good news the Stargate is
going off Prime
because it means they really are putting
the effort into epics and MGM plus that
we've been told they are
or is it bad news because something has
changed that we don't know about
and that's the thing that I'm a little
bit worried about what the hell is going
on with Stargate at the moment because
it seems to be very confused
I can't help but think that's a good
thing though guys I can't help but think
it's a good thing that we wouldn't be
talking about there wouldn't be so many
rumors out there there wouldn't be this
much smoke if there wasn't a fire
so let's just hope
but let's be honest We're Not Gonna know
until Amazon make the announcement but
hey it's fun to keep talking about
so guys if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you know I'm over in New York my wife is
not happy I'm making this video but you
know I'll go give you some smooches in a
second to make a print
please stay safe I'll see you next time
and UM Gators it's coming home let's
stay confident
[Music]